[Musik]
hey lieben wir machen heute einen
blätterteig ganz einfach weil ich mir
gedacht habe
perfekt zum grillen da muss man ja auch
mal was mitbringen sondern man muss
milch aber man nimmt er gerne was los
man sollte wenn man eingeladen ist oder
wenn man selber gilt dann also ich
persönlich hab das immer gern dass man
noch so kleine sparen kann habt dann
greift man sich hier und da was
und das kommt jetzt nicht auf dem grill
ihr könntet auch peter grill aber macht
es ruhig gerne auch im ofen und bereitet
das vor also ein blitzer tag kannst den
ich heute fühle mit einer spinat käse
füllung also ich meine feta käse
ich entscheide sogar spontan ob ich noch
genau damit dazu nehme ich hab letztens
auch bereit mit feta käse und gouda
gemachten auch sehr gut geschmeckt aber
ich starte jetzt zuallererst mal und
zwar habe ich hier blätterteig das ist
tiefster tag der ist ja dann immer so
rechteckig ihr könntet auch den aus der
kühltruhe nehmen aber ich habe immer
tiefgekühlten da sehe ich mir jetzt hier
auf meine schneidebrett und schneidet
ihn einmal diagonal durch den habe ich
zwei dreiecke und das mache ich jetzt so
mit den anderen blätterteig blättert er
über meister selbst und dann zeige ich
euch wie ihr das schichtet dann nämlich
heute nehme ich meine pizza blech aber
ihr könnt auch zum beispiel zu den
sprung vom boden nehmen fällt mir gerade
so 1
aber das zeige ich euch gleich um die
genauen mengenangaben findet ihr immer
in dem video beschreibung danke fürs
erinnern weil der franken auch noch
viele nach aber die sind bei mir immer
in der video beschreibung
[Musik]
so ein schnelles rezept sein so schönes
wetter draußen ihr solche nicht so lange
in der küche stehen dann muss es einfach
ruckzuck gehen und jetzt habe ich hier
tiefgekühlten spinal einfach komplett
auftauen lassen falls ihr euch sehr
westlich sein sollte dann versucht das
so ein bisschen wegzunehmen bei mir geht
es jetzt hier das ist übrigens
rahmspinat das würde auch mit normalem
spinat oder auch mit frischem
funktionieren so und da gebe ich jetzt
einmal gewürze dazu salz ein bisschen
moment da sind die korona die korona
funde und müssen sorgt ein bisschen muss
kann es nicht viel nur ein bisschen das
passt mal richtig kurzem spinat ist das
war schon und curry ich mag amateuren
spinal ich mag das total gerne so da
gibt es jetzt feta käse mit dazu einfach
rein bröselt und ich mach das ich mache
das ich gebe auch ein bisschen kauder
noch mit dazu gleich was machen einfach
geschmack und dann zieht sich das auch
ein bisschen ein bisschen habe ich ganz
vergessen
frisch gemeiner pfeffer schmidt so gut
tritt wird die füllung einfach verteilt
so ich glaube dass jetzt hier ein besser
ist wenn ihr dann den überraschenden
blätterteig einfach unten rein stopft so
ein bisschen versteckt dann kann ich es
auch nicht aufgehen und also ich muss ja
sagen gelangen habe bis jetzt gebraucht
haben soll realistische einschätzung
also ich jetzt auch drei minuten
geschätzt
anders als ich mich großartig river
trainieren und ich das irgendwie so weil
ich es drauf nehmen muss deswegen sagen
okay wir machen einfach nochmal also
haben sie was glaubst du wie lange er
hat es jetzt gedauert gesehen ja 34
minuten also das ist ein schnelles
rezept ich mache das jetzt also es
können jetzt auch direkt im backofen ich
hab's noch mit eigelb bestreichen ich
mache jetzt ein bisschen sesam darauf
richten das ist einfach schön aus
schwarz grün wird auch passt euch bleibt
heute nur bei sesam und dann backe ich
das bei 200 grad ober unterhitze im
vorgeheizten backofen bis es schön
goldbraun ist es kann so 20 bis 25
minuten dauern und dann können wir das
war messen
[Musik]
also der blätterteig kann es ist schnell
gemacht schmeckt sehr gut knusprig und
mir schmeckt am besten warm ihr könnt
ihn aber auch noch kalt genießen also
ihr müsst jetzt auch einen gefallen tun
ihr müsst mir am liebsten in die
kommentare schreiben was jetzt zum
sommer sehen möchtet also heute zum
beispiel ist es schon richtig warm ich
habe gerade was mit sahne gemacht habe
ich gemerkt ich schon also schmilzt
schon weg es wird wieder kälter wäre
dann genau dann wird es glaube ich
nächste woche wieder wärmer also
schreibt mir gerne eure sommer wünsche
rein was sie sehen möchte etwas
realistisch ist natürlich jetzt keine
dicke fette buttercremetorte oder sowas
sondern vielleicht keine rezepte
schreibt sie auf jeden fall rein gelesen
und das gemeinsam durch und bin ich auch
für das war ja ja und klassische bürger
auch jetzt fehlen diese abgespeckten
varianten
das machen wir das machen wir also auch
jetzt noch einen wunderschönen tag ich
hoffe das video hat euch gefallen die
last ein abo und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten rezept cherokee
[Musik]